hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
managering and monitoring inflammatory
bowel disease
i am sabrina lemos of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths and brought to
you by
diasoren for more information please
visit diasaurin.com
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as we want at any time you
want during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
your questions will be answered via
email
following the broadcast you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window and follow that
process to obtain your credits
i now present today's speaker dr anita
afazoli
associate professor of clinical medicine
and gastroenterologist that specializes
in inflammatory bowel disease
at the ohio state university wexner
medical center
for complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen dr fzali you
may now begin your presentation welcome
hello my name is anita apsali i'm a
gastroenterologist practicing at the
ohio state university wexner medical
center where i'm the medical director of
our osu
inflammatory bowel disease center so
today we're going to discuss
managing and monitoring inflammatory
bowel disease
and specifically the role of fecal cal
protected
i do have some financial disclosures as
listed here
[Music]
so we have three objectives for my talk
today
first we're going to describe
inflammatory bowel disease or
ibd and specifically it's
pathophysiology and
epidemiology i'd like for us to
understand the
treat to target goals in ibd and then
we're also
specifically again going to review the
role of fecal calprotectin or
fc in ibd
so as a wave of background let's talk
about the epidemiology of ibd
inflammatory bowel disease is an
idiopathic
chronic inflammatory disease for crohn's
disease it's really
any part of the gastrointestinal tract
that's involved
so we say from mouth to anus and then
for ulcerative colitis
as the name implies the inflammation is
limited only to the colon
inflammatory bowel disease is
characterized by both
activation or really dysregulation
of the immune system there's periods of
remission
where the patient is feeling very well
and their clinical disease and as well
as their mucosal disease is under
control
and then periods of relapse where their
inflammation is significant
they're having severe symptoms and they
are
flaring these symptoms vary widely
based on both location as well as
severity of
disease now it's important to note that
inflammatory bowel disease
ibd is not irritable bowel syndrome or
ibs traditionally we've regarded
inflammatory bowel disease to be
primarily in
a westernized type of disease pattern
specifically in the north american
or northern european countries before
the 1980s
these areas did in fact have the highest
prevalence of disease
but by contrast as you can see here
since 1990
the incidence of inflammatory bowel
disease has
increased in the industrialized
countries
as you can see here for crohn's disease
and the same
applies for ulcerative colitis
this increase in incidence has been
evident over time as described both for
ulster
colitis as well as for crohn's disease
and although previously thought to be
primarily a caucasian
disease we're actually seeing that the
incidence and the prevalence is
increasing among different
racial or ethnic groups
so what sort of symptoms does a patient
with ulcerative colitis have
well certainly there's change in bowel
patterns or bowel movements there's an
increased report of stool frequency as
well as the consistency
also varies and changes there's
abdominal pain mostly
left sided reported as cramping that's
also relieved with defecation
there's that incomplete feeling of a
full bowel movement or any
complete feeling of evacuation of that
and that's labeled as
tenismus and then bloody stools we do
use a clinical instrument called the
simple colitis activity index in clinic
to be able to evaluate the type of
symptoms reported by our patients
for crohn's disease based off of where
the patient's
disease is located that's where their
symptoms will occur
so specifically if they have mostly
colonic disease
they can have diarrhea if they have
mostly small bowel disease
they can have more abdominal pain and
constipation as opposed to diarrhea
weight loss fever rectal bleeding all of
these symptoms can be reported by our
patients again based off of the location
of their crohn's disease a clinical
instrument
excuse me a clinical instrument that we
use
is the harvey bradshaw index or hbi
for endoscopic features of inflammatory
bowel disease for ulcerative colitis
again this is primarily inflammation
in the colon and so this is a contiguous
circumferential inflammatory process
that starts in the rectum
and then can progress left-sided or even
pan-colonic
crohn's disease is more of a patchy
disease within the colon
and then again the involvement of the
small bowel or elsewhere
the type of inflammation we see i'll
show you some pictures here
and then also the type of disease
phenotype that's based off of whether we
see strictures
or fistulas or other types of of a
phenotype progression
based off of radiographic imaging as
well
so let's look at some endoscopic
pictures
so what is the role of colonoscopy in
inflammatory bowel disease here i've
shared three different pictures we have
the terminal ilium with the microvilli
then we have the normal colon so in the
middle
and on the right side we have pictures
of a normal colon
normal vascular pattern normal half
straw or folds within the colon
this is not normal so here for
ulcerative colitis
you can see that the inflammation can be
mild can become more moderate or even
significant or severe
based off of the amount of inflammation
and the severity of the inflammation we
see
within the lining of the colon or the
mucosa of the colon
[Music]
for crohn's disease we don't necessarily
have a spectrum
but certainly the type of lesions that
we see
tells us how severe or significant the
disease is
so on the top left you see small atheist
ulcers
but then you see more severe ulcerations
the
the cratered ulcer like lesions that you
see in the top right
the cervigenous linear ulcerations that
you see in the bottom
left as well as severe ulceration
structuring scarring and a cobblestone
pattern of the mucosa that you see on
the bottom
right so how do we diagnose inflammatory
bowel disease well basically we
have to of course gather a history from
our patients what type of symptoms are
they having
if physical examination is important
laboratory testing is also very
important for us to be able to evaluate
if there's evidence of anemia for
example malabsorption of the other
vitamins or nutrients
biomarkers and we will discuss the role
of fecal calprotectin
stool studies to rule out an infection
endoscopy
cross-sectional imaging again
specifically for crohn's disease and to
evaluate the disease phenotype
specifically within the small bowel as
well as other additional diagnostic
studies as listed out here
so when we talk about managing a patient
with inflammatory bowel disease
it's extremely important to make the
diagnosis quickly
and accurately we need to be able to
differentiate between disease
activity and disease severity we need to
be able to help our patients feel better
patient reported outcomes is a very
important
and we need to make sure that their
symptoms are under control
and their quality of life is back to
their baseline
we need to be able to induce remission
rapidly
and maintain a steroid free remission
over time
we call this deep remission where we've
not only achieved clinical remission
but also mucosal healing so we've been
able to achieve mucosal healing
when we're evaluating by endoscopy or
other measures
we know that this is all very important
because this
in totality helps modifier or improve
the long-term disease outcomes for our
patients with inflammatory bowel disease
in turn we're able to avoid
hospitalizations
surgery a disabling disease course
we're able to reduce the steroid
exposure opioids exposure
and we reduce costs of care for managing
our patients
now at present our current evaluation
whether we're using those clinical
instruments scores that i mentioned
earlier or even by endoscopy
all of that is truly a cross-sectional
assessment of how our patient is doing
today in other words the short-term
activity of their disease
the disease severity includes elements
of a prognosis for the patient
specifically
to be able to predict how is their
disease going to do
over time so from here you can see that
there are certainly prognostic factors
either for crohn's disease or for
ulcerative colitis
which helps us predict over time how
much
at risk are they for their disease to
progress
for their disease to potentially require
hospitalization
steroids surgery etc so for crohn's
disease that moderate or high risk
factors as listed out here
and the same for ulcerative colitis
where we have high risk factors as
listed
out wise is important
again as you can see from this picture
we really only have a small
window of opportunity to improve the
disease
control symptoms and potentially avoid
the natural
progression of the disease which could
become a structuring
fibrostenotic fistulizing disease course
so if we are able to target
these specific targets that i'll talk to
you about
we could potentially change the natural
progression of the disease
and potentially reduce or eliminate the
risk of the patient's disease
progressing
to a fibrostenotic structuring disease
course
and in turn we could potentially avoid
surgeries
for our patients with crohn's disease as
well as hospitalizations
need for steroids or having other
debilitating factors related to their
disease
the same goes for ulcerative colitis
with better disease control
we could improve the inflammation within
their colon
and even reduce their risk for colon
cancer for example
and so we know that if we control the
inflammation
in turn our patients do better and it
results in better
outcomes long-term outcomes for our
patients
so how do we approach this well
importantly we've recognized over time
that certainly we want our patients to
feel better but we need to move to more
objective measures or targets
so of course again our goal is to be
able to have our patients respond to
treatment
and with that response they improve they
have improved symptoms
and improve quality of life but if we
are if our goal is remission or more so
deep remission you can see that we want
to not only improve their symptoms
we want to eliminate their symptoms that
they previously had
we want to achieve normal laboratory or
biomarkers
we want to achieve a normal endoscopy we
want to achieve mucosal healing
and from those goals you can see that
we're not only able to improve
quality of life over reducing the
disabling disease
course potentially for our patients
including reducing
reducing risk for disability or
minimizing that
reducing the risk or potentially
avoiding surgery
so it's important for us to have a
sustained disease control
with achieving the deep remission and
utilizing these
objective treat to targets
so what should these objective targets
be
well this was a stride group an
international group
which basically helped us determine what
some of these targets should be
whether we're discussing ulcerative
colitis or crohn's disease
so for ulcerative colitis the patient
reported outcomes and specifically a
resolution of rental bleeding
and diarrhea or their ultraviolet habits
as well as
endoscopic remission and we use an
endoscopy
mayo scoring system and so an endoscopic
score of zero to one is
and should be our targets for managing
our patients with ulcerative colitis
histologic remission is an adjunctive
goal
for crohn's disease again of course our
target should be there we want our
patients to feel better
patient reported outcomes and
specifically resolution of abdominal
pain
and diarrhea or their ultra bowel habits
as well
as endoscopic remission so again a
resolution of the inflammation or
ulceration
excuse me or ulceration seen on ileal
colonoscopy
as well as resolution of findings of
inflammation seen on cross-sectional
imaging
again for the patient with small bowel
crohn's disease for example
so these are objective targets that we
should aim for
our patients in order to achieve better
outcomes
now biomarker remission whether it's a
normalization of their
c reactive protein or their fecal cal
protectant
has now been considered an adjunctive
target
and so do does this matter and the quick
answer and short answer is yes
achieving a treat to target for our
patients not only is it possible
but we're able to have better outcomes
for our patients and that's our goal
so this was a retrospective study to
determine whether a real world practice
of treat to target is possible
so one group basically performed the
normal approach without
achieving or attempting to achieve
mucosal healing
and the other group attempted that more
stringently or specifically
so from the group that was able to apply
the
treat to target approach for mucosal
healing with making dose adjustments to
the patient's therapy
you can see that in fact mucosal healing
was
achieved as was histologic healing
and so with this these patients had a
better
treatment as well as a management
outcome course
[Music]
the column study was an additional study
in a more recent study that demonstrated
that the treat-to-target
approach leads to superior endoscopic
outcomes as well as those deep remission
outcomes as i described earlier
so two different groups randomized to
either the typical clinical management
group that we used before
which was basically assessing whether
our patients are feeling better
providing steroids when needed and
mostly monitoring
symptoms then there was the treat to
target group
which was now not only driven by
symptoms because that is again a
the patient reported outcomes and
symptoms reported is and should be our
target
but also utilizing some objective
targets and here the objective target
included fecal calprotectin
as well as the c reactive protein and
then also evaluation of need for
steroids for the patients
so dose modifications to their treatment
and specifically in this study it was
for adeline
those modifications were made based off
of whether or not there was an elevation
in these objective targets as listed
and from the com study we found that the
treat to target approach
was and help achieve superior outcomes
for our patients
as opposed to the clinical management
approach here the patients had
with being able to apply those
inflammatory biomarkers specifically
fecal calprotectin c
reactive protein you can see that the
patients were able to achieve
better mucosal healing less deep
ulcerations on the endoscopy that was
performed
as compared to clinical management and
symptom
management alone
so this is not anything new in fact we
know
in fact even since the early 1990s
that basically the clinical outcomes
does not correlate
with endoscopic outcomes nor does
how one is feeling today impact what
we will see over time on endoscopy with
the amount of inflammation
and scarring potentially that the
patient will have
we also know and what has been already
described
is that if we achieve mucosal healing
for our patients
whether crohn's disease or ulcerative
colitis
we are able to reduce their risk reduce
the need for surgical
intervention as described here for
crohn's disease
patients were less likely to require
surgery for their crohn's disease
if mucosal healing was achieved and the
same for ulcerative colitis
so how do we approach this well it's
important to make sure that we
individualize our therapy and our
treatment and our targets
for each individual patient so initially
as you can see here
we certainly want to make the initial
accurate diagnosis
we need to be able to assess what our
targets should be
we need to be able to adjust our therapy
based off of whether or not our patients
have achieved
those targets and we need to
continuously monitor this
how do i propose this well initially
again based off of the stride
recommendations
patient reported outcomes are important
endoscopy is important as well as any
additional studies as listed how out
here
so imaging or enterography laboratory
test
fecal cal protection you see that i've
listed it out a few times here
and this is how i propose that we
approach our treat to target management
individualized for each of our patients
so here
at baseline it's important to obtain a
fecal cal protectant
and potentially monitoring and utilizing
this biomarker
over time to determine whether or not
adjustments in therapy
is necessary so certainly today i'm not
going to talk about all of our different
therapies we have
for managing our patients with
inflammatory bowel disease
but more so to remind you that we have a
medicine cabinet
and regardless of which treatment we
decide to initiate for our patients
we need to be able to monitor to ensure
that our patients have achieved
those targets as i described
so let's take a step and look at
specifically at fecal cal protectant
what role does it have
well as you may know fecal cal protector
or calprotectin is a calcium binding
protein from the s-100 family
it's a neutrophil protein found in both
plasma and stool
with levels about six times higher in
the stool compared to the plasma
we do know that fecal cal protectant is
increased in both
a patient with an infection as well as
inflammatory conditions or specifically
inflammatory bowel disease
and we've learned that fecal
calprotectin can be used as a
non-invasive marker
of neutrophilic intestinal inflammation
specifically for us practicing
gastroenterology and ivd specifically
we have actually found that we've been
able to differentiate
whether our patient has inflammatory
bowel disease
from irritable bowel syndrome based off
of a fecal cal protectant
so here compared to the other
inflammatory biomarkers whether it's
c-reactive protein or esr
you can see that a calprotectin cutoff
value of 30
has a 100 sensitivity 97
specificity for differentiating from
crohn's disease
versus irritable bowel syndrome of note
i also want to remind you that about 30
percent of the general population
does not mount a c-reactive protein or
crp
response their liver does not mount that
response regardless of whether they have
an
infection or inflammation
how good is calprotectin in diagnosing
inflammatory bowel disease well
not only can we differentiate it but we
also know that based off of numerous
studies
and elevated fecal calprotectin is
consistent
and and also helpful in diagnosing
inflammatory bowel disease regardless of
whether our patient is an adult patient
or even a child
so a positive there what has been found
in these studies is that there is a
positive correlation
of fecal calprotectin and fecal
excretion
so this supports the hypotheses of a
neutrophil migration
into the gut lumen across any form of
inflamed mucosa again
either because of inflammatory bowel
disease or because of an
infection even and based off of the
newer assays that there are
newer cut off values suggested
how good is fecal cow protectant for
assessment of endoscopic healing
or histologic healing well recall from
my earlier slides i mentioned to you
again that the importance of
endoscopic and even potentially
histologic
healing again we know that this improves
outcomes this is one of our targets
mucosal healing
so from this you can see that it is in
fact a good marker for disease activity
this was a study for evaluation of
adults with
active ulcerative colitis based off of
both endoscopy
as well as histology and the study found
that
higher levels of fecal calprotectin was
associated with
active disease as opposed to mild or
inactive ulcer of colitis as described
here the median fecal cal protectant of
active ulcerative colitis
was 68 as compared to mild or no
active disease of referral surplus being
11 and a half
and in the control group a level of six
how good is fecal cal protection for
subclinical disease
activity in a patient with ulcerative
colitis that's
asymptomatic but we know that they have
ulcerative colitis so we do know that we
need to follow and monitor
objective metrics or targets so this was
a multi-center
cross-sectional study of about 370
patients
two different forms of assays were used
the quantum blue
as well as a fluoroamino assay and from
this
irrespective of which assay was used
the for for detecting fecal calprotectin
levels
there was a significant difference
compared to ulcerative colitis patients
with
or without histologic and or endoscopic
disease
activity so on your right you can see
that the patient
with active ulcer colitis based off of
the mayo score so
here you can see in blue if they had
less severe male or endoscopic score
their fecal cal protectant was lower the
same goes
waste based off of whether we're using
the mayo score
or the ultra client's endoscopic score
again a less severe endoscopy score
was associated with less of
a level of or lower of the level of
fecal cal protected
the gaboe scores based off of histology
so if the histologic
activity was low again fecal cal
protectant
was low compared to if the endoscopy
score was higher or the histology score
was higher
we do know that again the patients even
if they are asymptomatic
we do know that it's associated with
more active
objective disease
for calprotectin for that subclinical
disease activity
again when we're looking at fecal
calprotectin and the lipocalin was
another biomarker that they tested
fecal calprotectin was actually superior
compared to by the other biomarker
lipocalin
and pretty similar to the endoscopic or
other uh the histologic assessment but
from here it cut off values of 150
or 250 again based off of the
the fecal calprotectin assay that was
used had a good balance for sensitivity
specificity in the both the positive
as well as the negative predictive value
the overall accuracy as well as the
capital index is as listed out here
how good is fecal calculator tecton for
evaluating response to treatment
well again i'm highlighting to you that
it's very important to make sure we've
been able to achieve
the the targets as initially outlined
for each individual patient these
objective targets or goals and
specifically of achieving mucosal
healing
is extremely important well in the past
the primary approach for that was
endoscopy more another colonoscopy
another colonoscopy
well certainly we do know that this is
an invasive
procedure it could be quite costly it
has
risks involved and let's be honest most
patients
don't want to even have frequent
endoscopic evaluation
because of all the reasons as and their
concerns as
as we are well aware of now we do know
that despite
mucosal healing being a goal as far as a
treatment or a treat to target goal
endoscopy based monitoring is performed
only about 50 percent of the time
after a patient is initiated on biologic
therapy
and with fecal calprotectin it's really
only utilized about five percent of the
time
so this was a recent study with pooled
data from different phase two trials for
both biologics and
numerous different biologics as well as
the oral small molecule
top ascendant and really it was pulled
data to evaluate
how well fecal cal protectant is in
achieving
endoscopic healing and so from this a
fecal cal protectant of 50 or less
had a sensitivity of 82 specificity of
74
in evaluation or achieving or diagnosing
endoscopic healing
a fecal cal protectant based off the
pooled individual data from the studies
a fecal cal protectant of greater than
250
had a sensitivity of 76 and a
specificity of 79
in diagnosing endoscopic healing
so let's look at and what the authors
looked at was scenario specific
characteristics for fecal cal protectant
so from the first scenario in order with
the patients with the individual data
pool with a fecal cal protectant
of 50 or less and the patient's having a
rectal
bleeding score of zero or a
stool frequency score or sfs
of zero or one you can see that the
positive predictive value
for fecal cal protectant of less than 50
was 90
for those patients that had improved
after
induction of treatment and for the
endoscopic
improvement after maintenance of
treatment
a fecal cal protectant of less than 50
had
a positive predictive value of 96
percent
so from here you can see that the fecal
cal protectant
performance decreases when the patient
has
increased stool frequency score and a
fecal cal protection of greater
than 50 is not a good test in
diagnosting
diagnosing endoscopic active disease
what about additional specific scenarios
that we can potentially see how the uh
fecal cal protectant plays a role
so here for a fecal cal protected score
of greater than 250 for moderate to
severe
endoscopic disease after induction
a rectal bleeding score of two or three
or stool frequency score of two or three
had a positive predictive value of 97
percent for a fecal cal calprotectin
cutoff of 250
and for moderate to severe endoscopic
disease
maintenance a positive predictive value
of 95
for a fecal calprotectin cutoff of
greater than 250.
here you can see again that the fecal
calprotectin cutoff performance
decreases when the fecal calprotectin
level is less than 250
or rectal bleeding is less severe
so how or what would be a good proposed
algorithm for both the patient reported
outcomes and symptoms
and the role for fecal cal protectant
for evaluation of disease activity
so here is a good great outline of an
algorithm of how to approach this
and the values as listed out here
so for the patient report outcome if
they're in complete resolution of rectal
bleeding or near normalization of stool
frequency
with the fecal cal protection of less
than 50 there's a
very high likelihood of achieving
treatment targets
and specifically a high correlation with
the mayo endoscopy score
of zero or one so potentially in these
patients we don't need to do another or
perform another colonoscopy
but rather base it on the fecal
calprotectin level
for the patient with ongoing rectal
bleeding symptoms greater than 50
of their bowel movements having blood
or passage of the blood in the patient
who has persistent stool frequency of
greater than three stools above their
baseline
and if their fecal cal protected score
is greater than 250
then this is associated with a very high
likelihood
of having moderate to severe endoscopic
activity a mayo endoscopy score of two
or three
and in these patients you don't
necessarily need to do a colonoscopy
to determine whether they have active
disease and
just based off of the fecal cow
protectant and their symptoms
we know that they have active disease
what role does fecal calprotectin have
for prediction of relapse
well inflammatory bowel disease as i've
described at the start of my talk
has periods of remission and relapse
these clinical symptoms may not
necessarily be a good assessment of how
they're doing
as far as their mucosal active
inflammation in fact
about 50 percent of our patients with
inflammatory bowel
disease have a functional component or a
component of irritable bowel syndrome
also again we do know that fecal
calprotectin
correlates very nicely with endoscopic
as well as histological
inflammation as i shared with you so for
the patient to determine whether we
could predict relapse relapse with
utilizing fecal cal protected
this was a study and a reminder that yes
in fact it is a good
non-invasive marker for not only
evaluation of active disease
but also for disease relapse a cutoff
value of 50
and a 13-fold increased risk or
telling us that our patient is at a
13-fold increased risk for a relapse
of either ulcerative colitis or crohn's
disease
so putting this all together again
there's multiple roles for
fecal cal protectant in our treat to
target approach
in evaluation of a really objective
evaluation of whether mucosal healing
endoscopic healing histologic healing
has been
achieved in our patients so how do i
suggest putting this all together
well at baseline at the initial time of
diagnosis
it's important to obtain a fecal cal
protectant determine what the level is
at baseline over time once you've
initiated therapy so the induction of
treatment
responds to the treatment maintenance of
therapy
during this time i recommend obtaining a
fecal cal protection
at least every three to six months
potentially even sooner
based off of how they're responding to
the treatment you have initiated for the
patient
certainly if they're having a relapse in
their disease
then the role of fecal calprotectin as i
demonstrated to you
is helpful and then also for the patient
who would like to discontinue their
therapy
in this role again fecal calprotectin is
important
because it can also help predict the
relapse but then also determining if
they've truly achieved
mucosal healing
so in summary remember that inflammatory
bowel disease is a global disease
it's important to be able to
differentiate disease activity which is
the short term how is your patient
currently doing from disease severity
which are
really the long term outcomes how is
your patient going to do
over time specifically if you have not
achieved
those targets as i described to you
prognosis is based on each of the
individuals disease
factors it's important for us to be able
to individualize our targets for each of
our patients
and certainly our patients don't want to
have a colonoscopy every few
months or weeks even in the appropriate
patient for the obvious reasons that are
well known so it's very important to be
able to better utilize some of these
non-invasive biomarkers
such as fecal calprotectin and i hope
i've been able to demonstrate to you
that
truly fecal calprotectin plays a
significant role
for monitoring and managing the patient
with inflammatory bowel disease
and with that i thank you for your
attention and i welcome any questions